hi everybody thank you so much for
tuning in to our second
now annual panel on diversity at informs
i'm tessa childersday i started at
amazon as a data scientist
five and a half years ago and i now
manage a team of scientists that focus
on forecasting for the supply chain
we predict demand for the individual
products that are sold on amazon's
website
and in our physical stores and these
forecasts are used to make decisions
about what to buy
when to buy it and where to place it
these and other decisions help
our get our customers what they need
when they need it
at a great price um today we're going to
be bringing together a panel of women to
discuss
innovation and diversity at amazon
to innovate is to make changes in
something established
especially by introducing new methods
ideas or products
and diversity is divine defined as the
condition
of having or being composed of differing
elements
when looking at those two definitions
together it struck me
that the pace of discovery and
introduction of these new ideas
is certainly enriched by the existence
of differing elements
and while amazon is by no means perfect
one of the clearest ways
we focus on innovation and diversity is
through our leadership principles
including our commitments to think big
because we believe that in order to look
around corners to serve
our customers we must avoid the
self-fulfilling prophecy of thinking
small instead creating a bold direction
that inspires results we do that by
thinking differently
by innovating moreover we really try to
focus on being right a lot
not because you have to be to be able to
tell the future at amazon
although i must admit it helps if you
work in forecasting like i do
but because we think that by seeking
diverse perspectives and actively
working to disconfirm our beliefs
will improve the quality of the
decisions that we all have to make on a
daily basis
so um i wanted to highlight a little bit
some of the teams
that focus on innovation in the areas
of optimization that may particularly be
of interest
um to those of you that are tuning in
today so
i work in scott
scott is the supply chain optimization
technologies
um area and this is the organization
that is behind our ability to make a
promise to our customer so every time a
customer places an order on amazon.com
we make a promise to you to deliver your
item to you quickly
scott is the is the organization
that backs up that promise it it's the
organization that tells you um that you
can get
get you what you need when you need it
and at a great price
we use advanced techniques and
technologies including machine learning
and data science
to predict demand to forecast inventory
needs and to select suppliers
some of our other teams that are doing
optimization include folks like middle
mile research and optimization science
and this is an area that focuses on
logistics
they're charged with developing an
evolving suite of decision support and
optimization tools
including facilitating the design of
efficient air and ground transport
networks
optimizing the flow of packages within
the network efficiently aligning network
capacity
and shipment demand and many other
things
mop or modeling and optimization team is
another team
they use mathematical optimization
algorithm design statistics and machine
learning
and they improve decision making
capabilities
across our operating operations and
logistics teams
focusing on transportation topology
labor and resource planning for
fulfillment centers
we also use optimization in our customer
service teams
we use them in our amazon robotics teams
where we make decisions about
picking packing and shipping millions of
orders a day
deciding how to dynamically rearrange
our inventory for efficient retrieval
and many many more
i'd like to take this opportunity as
well to
introduce all of our panelists and so
we're going to go through
and i'm going to ask each of you to tell
us a little bit
about how long you've been at amazon
what you do now
and how your background has helped you
to be successful
and if you don't mind irene i'm going to
ask you to go first sure
um so i've been at amazon for around 3.5
years now
and i'm a product i'm a principal
product manager at inventory planning
and control
also known as ipc within scott and as a
product manager the products
that i develop and own are inventory
optimization systems and models
that basically decide things like
how much to buy where to place within
the amazon
fulfillment network so i naturally work
very closely with
business engineering and science
so i got my phd in or from columbia and
having this background
basically not only helped me work better
with science but it also gave me the
confidence that when needed
or when i wanted i can get dipped into
science
and knowing that i think helped me to be
successful in my role
as well as to broaden my school
awesome thanks so much uh muge would you
mind telling us a little bit about your
background as well
yeah um hi everyone my name is miguel
dogen and
i've been at amazon 13 years now i got
my phd in operations research and
chemical engineering from carnegie
mellon
and i was really interested in joining
supply chain at amazon
and interestingly i met with ping who is
a part of this panel today
at informs and i remember us talking
about the culture
and the science roles and you know how
how it all drives and whether or not
she's using the things that she's
learned
during her phd as a part of her job and
she said yes
to all of those things um i ended up
joining our advertising business to do
or yield optimization and pricing models
and after a few years i joined our
retail business as a functional leader
and then moved to general management and
right now i lead engineering
science operations and business leading
our last mile delivery and pick up
businesses worldwide
it's really awesome to hear that the
connections that people make at informs
uh really actually pan out to be such
long-lasting relationships at amazon
oslo do you want to go next and tell us
a little bit about your journey to
joining amazon
yes um i have been at amazon for
nine years now um i got my phd from
stanford management
science and engineering department and i
joined amazon
right after that i'm a senior operations
research scientist in
modeling and optimization team what i
do is i work on models that optimize how
shipments are delivered
to customers to minimize cost and
maximize speed i write optimization
models develop
algorithms and heuristics to help us
decide how to fulfill
the brown boxes people receive when they
order something on amazon
that's really cool um ping would you
mind telling us a little bit about how
you came to join amazon
all right hey everyone thanks for coming
today
uh you know i just uh
got my in amazon would call the purple
badge so
uh last month it was my 15th anniversary
amazon
uh it was crazy it's hard for me to
fathom that i spend this much time here
but anyway it still feels like
exciting there's a lot of stuff to do
interesting problem to be solved
and also it just feels like yesterday
like i don't know 13 years ago or not
when miguel and i met at informs
like i didn't feel like we aged that
much we looked pretty much the same
and it really just felt like yesterday
um so i
started uh like i said i got my phd from
the or center at mit
um i actually interned on amazon um and
then started a number of collaborations
with amazon at the time
and it's uh it's been 15 years i was in
the last
i started at the entry level clearly uh
or scientists um i was actually in the
team that
uh oslon is in right now for four years
and then in the last 10 years i spend a
lot of time in forecasting
so really doing a lot more machine
learning learning um
but also taking the data feeding into
all the optimization problems
today i run two organizations
one is we call this top line forecasting
essentially you can think of as a
revenue units forecast that's being fed
through many teams within the company
for financial planning
labor planning capacity planning even
marketing related planning
and so that's one organization and the
other organization is where
texas teams that continue to manage the
skill level forecasting team
well now that we've heard a little bit
about how all of you came to amazon and
where you are now
i think it's really clear that sort of
the tie that binds us all together is
that we are
all um women in um stem at amazon
and i think one of the really inspiring
things is
that as um as female leaders
um at amazon which is a fairly large
corporation i think
uh the people who are tuning in are
asking themselves you know what does it
look like
to work as a woman in stem or to be a
female leader
here and i think um everyone on this
panel is coming from a different
experience and from a different place
and so i'd love to hear a little bit
more about that from each of your
perspectives and experiences
movie i thought maybe we could start
with you sure
like i mentioned my background is
chemical engineering and
throughout my schooling as an engineer
um female engineers were
a handful and got further diminished at
the phd level
um kind of in contrast to that i think
what i love about working
at amazon as a female leader is a couple
of things
um first of all there aren't any
stereotypes here we
live and breed in our leadership
principles which are about
customer obsession and invention um
second i've i have two kids and i've had
both of my kids while working at amazon
and my
um significant other also works at
amazon
and there is no face time here like if
you need to leave early to pick up your
kids from daycare you do it it's okay
if you can't come to a meeting 7 30 a.m
because you have you know
responsibilities you have to take your
kids to school whatever it is
it's okay nobody minds not frowned upon
nobody even cares
um as long as you do your job and
deliver results you're okay
um and i would say finally a writing
culture
i think is a is a huge differentiator i
feel it democratizes the process and
communication
doesn't matter what your background is
does it matter if you're very
charismatic or not
or a great orator if you can write which
many of us
in this room in this informs forum uh
have a lot of practice of doing that
and you can get your ideas out there
having said that of course numbers
matter and i think at amazon we've made
a lot of progress in this in the past
few years
by adding more female leaders to really
senior positions
numbers are important because women
might feel their career path is
unprecedented
seeing more leaders and being mentored
by them
especially ones you identify with who
has been successful
tells you that you can do it too
you can see yourself at that position
and i think
that's a great starting point
i totally agree um and i
really excited to hear irene's
perspective on this
sure so i wanted to be one more woman
in the team in amazon stem is still
considered as a male dominant area like
to give you example
when i first joined the ipc new york
my current team i was the only woman in
my team for a while
so given that i really wanted to
help and encourage more women to join
them especially
so as a female leader at amazon i try to
do
small things which all other female
leaders are trying to do in amazon
such as making myself available for
mentorship
and we also have amazon women in
engineering and we
hold regular lunch and learns where the
female panelists
hold sessions ability like this so i
like to participate in those to make
sure that
i can be part of people in leadership
who's encouraging more women to feel
more comfortable and confident to be in
stem
and also i'm very cautious of how i
present myself at work since i want to
set the right example for other female
leaders to come
so as much mentioned amazon has the
culture with
strong emphasis on the leadership
principles
rather than certain gender stereotypes
and i want to make sure that none of my
behaviors are tagged with gender
stereotype types so that we can keep
this amazing culture
where we focus on people's delivery and
work rather than
like who you are or what your background
is gender is
gotcha thank you aslan do you want to go
next
yes um so i haven't worked in any
company other than amazon so i don't
have a good comparison point but
what i can say is this we definitely
need more women around us um
in most meetings i am the only woman
um and i have been to some meetings in
the past where people start speaking
over each other and
won't have to speak up um be speak up to
be heard and interrupt others and to
make their points
um so but nonetheless things are getting
better i think people are aware now more
aware that
the of the difficulties women are facing
in the workplace
um it is also now easier to find other
women
other successful women leaders to look
up to um compared to when i first
started
so i think we are moving in the right
direction i'm really excited about it
i would agree the the presence of women
and
and women mentorship and even the
acknowledgement
that that representation matters has
certainly improved over the past
years ping would you like to go next
sure uh you might hear some children
background noise
uh in the back this is at the end of the
school
so uh in case you're wondering what that
is
you know um as a female amazon um
i have to be honest and most of the time
you know we're focusing on work
i don't think twice about it but i have
to say sometimes i get into a meeting
especially a large one
uh i might get this reaction like whoa
this is like my tea days
uh you know uh clearly because of the
stem
um stem uh field
and then there were other times that i
would get into another meeting such as
this one
and it's like all female and you all get
excited you know you're like hey
that's cool your shoes are really cool
that's the ones when i've been wanting
to buy
um it feels really exciting um but but
the mental model i have is you know
amazon is a pretty uh
large but decentralized company i don't
know if you guys heard that we have this
concept of kind of a pizza team
right you have a team that's uh just
self-sufficient
they manage this product they make a lot
of decisions empowered to make a lot of
decisions
and so as a leader i think a lot about
how do we create a culture
especially for our own organization um
that's you know diversity friendly if i
can call it
so you know i've had personally i've had
a female manager for
more than five years at some point in my
career uh
there were two managers in my management
training were female
and all of us had kids you know i have
two kids a five-year-old and a
two-year-old
and so i do think it makes a difference
it's not just a representation
that you know you're mindful that you
have you know pickups and drop-offs and
school day offs and so especially in
colby being a parent named karen is
really challenging
so um i think that you know just as as a
manager
showing small gestures you know such as
hey you know
today it was being really tough because
schools all of a sudden
shut down or you know finding ways to
advocate
uh more kind of larger initiatives for
really
work-life flexibility so um
well i do believe that we need to get
our numbers up in terms of
representation stem
i think that we also need to advocate
for organizational culture that's
friendly
uh to the variety of needs that folks
have including female
absolutely absolutely well thank you all
for talking
a little bit about your um
about your general experience about
being a woman in stem or a leader at
amazon
um i think a couple of folks alluded to
needing representation and needing women
around you to be able to look up to
but i thought it would be helpful if we
talked really explicitly about the
importance of mentorship
in one's career um and so i was
i was hoping that we could talk about um
the importance of mentorship in your
career
perhaps how um how have other women
throughout your career
impacted your growth and success or
maybe when you have acted as a mentor
yourself
to others um and i thought we could
start with irene
this time so
having a right mentor in career for me
is like the having
the right life coach and i've always had
at least
one female mentor at any given point of
time in my career
and this is like really important for me
because
i want to seek advice from someone i can
resonate with and at the same time
i want to get advice from the female
leaders that i respect
so for example being here is actually my
mentor
and i've been since i joined amazon i've
been going to her
multiple times to seek advice on various
situations so one good example is that
i am an introvert and i do not like
asking questions speaking of in large
meetings
especially if it's not absolutely
necessarily especially like
i did have many examples of people
talking over me
so all those kind of like discourage me
even more
so and i've been called out on this
multiple times so i actually talked to
ping about
this and sick for advice
and what she told me is that actually
there's nothing wrong with
being an intro introvert but
what i needed is that i need to find a
mechanism to make sure that my opinions
are shared and my voice is heard but i
just need to find that mechanism that
works for
myself and it doesn't necessarily have
to be
i need to be the one who is speaking up
loud in the large meetings
so given that i've advised the mechanism
i took is writing and as mukey said
amazon is document and writing driven
culture
so this type of communication mechanism
actually worked out
very well for me and very effective and
contributed to my success
i think the essence of her advice is
that you do not need to force yourself
to be
someone else but you need to find a
mechanism that works for you
to present yourself at your best
especially working in
male dominant industry as a woman i
think it's crucial to find the mechanism
to be yourself
and be confident about it because i
believe you perform the best when you
don't have to pretend to be someone else
yeah i think that authenticity piece
that staying true to yourself
is really important um otherwise
i think you might succeed but trying to
but but feeling like you're you're
spoofing someone else is probably not
going to
to lead to longevity in your career so
that that's a very sage piece of advice
i would say
muslim what about you
um so my first mentor
uh was a woman also at amazon um and she
helped me tremendously i cannot say it
um
highly enough um i'm also shy um and
i mean i'm sorry um i she helped me how
to speak up how to get
feedback and how to ask for help uh she
made me realize that
it's okay to ask for help and things
don't have to be perfect before i put
right put things out and she was the
person i felt i could openly talk to you
about these things
and i felt easier to open up to a woman
which i think is a common feeling shared
by most junior women
this type of help like this type of
advice i got from her
is very important for work-life success
and it's easier to get it from a woman
from a mentor compared to
colleagues or a manager or just friends
that is why i highly recommend everyone
to get a
mentor and i try to pay it forward it's
it's uh it's very important i don't
forget the help i get from her
and it's very important to help the
younger generation especially women
absolutely um ping i think we've already
heard from irene
we know that you are a mentor um when
would you
would you like to share a little bit
more about mentorship you've
either given or received in the past
yeah
absolutely well great great a lot of fun
having conversations i
ain't glad i can help in any ways i i
tend to think of mentorship as just you
know in order to be successful
really as anybody uh you need to have a
support network
right and it could be your colleague
your your friends on the team
your uh your manager even a mentor could
be one of them
but also you know sponsors uh just
general folks that
that that would help support you uh to
grow
um and so i one of the things i do enjoy
doing
is mentor folks um and so i
kind of worked out with my ea that you
know i have a certain
chunk on my calendar that i book out for
um for mentorship and uh
more lately i would say i've been
prioritizing females um
just because you know we all think about
how do we get the numbers up in stem
sure we can try recruiting but also like
how do you help
even kind of the middle layer not even
just entry layer
folks female leaders to be even more
successful
um and i do really um enjoy it i i find
that folks come to me
for um i would say just things that are
could be because they feel more
comfortable talking to female
it could be their own insecurities like
why isn't that person listening to me uh
or maybe that's not really insecurity
that's a fact
but it could be that um something
extremely
uh personal uh that they just
don't feel comfortable sharing at all
with somebody who's
uh male regardless of you know how just
that person is
um and um and one of i would say most
recent example is i've had somebody
coming as uh you know still growing as a
manager
um and so you know after we met a couple
times for a couple quarters um
she was doing really well and she was
surprisingly
getting a fast promotion um so that was
really exciting
so we kind of celebrate that so overall
i would say yes i don't know if it's
mentorship but do whatever it takes
to make you feel like you support it
absolutely i think that makes a lot of
sense
um okay the
um i think that talking about mentorship
and especially
i think that what ping was sort of
getting at is the role in retention and
advancement as well as in
in recruitment is really important um
and i wanted to also talk about
um what is like another thing
that keeps people um uh excited
and happy about amazon and so um i was
curious
just in general what is it that um all
of you like the best about being at
amazon or what is it that keeps you
excited about coming to work every day
um and i thought we would start again
with irene this time
sure so what i like the most about
amazon
is ask for forgiveness not permission
culture
so basically you're given a freedom to
believe do what you believe is the right
thing to do which may blur the
boundaries
across chalk families and functions
and you're given an opportunity to shape
your own
role so for example i am a product major
but i do come with the science
background but my role is not confined
to just product management i can tap
into other things if i like
so you do not need to stick to a mindset
of
oh but there hasn't been such a role
before in amazon
actually i had exact this conversation
with my manager and his response was
you should not think like day two amazon
is still at day one meaning i can always
be the first example
of something i mean of course amazon has
ownership like had strong focus on
ownership to make sure there's a balance
between freedom and responsibility
but the fact that there is an
opportunity
to shape my own role that fits who i am
excites me the most
absolutely i think it's pretty common
when someone new starts for them to ask
you know like what's your one piece of
advice and i always say you know at
amazon very few people are gonna
ask you to do something like step in and
do it and i think that's sort of what
you're getting at with the ask
forgiveness not permission
like like lean in and i think it you're
you're less likely to get in trouble for
doing something than you are for not
doing something like it's it's more
important to get out there and and do it
um do you want to tell us a little bit
about
uh what you like the most about amazon
and what you're most excited about here
yes sure um what i do
what i like most about amazon is that
what i
do at amazon has an impact i see my
models being used
and they are making a difference um and
that's hugely satisfying
and i uh learn something every day the
learning opportunities are endless uh i
work at
i get to work with smart and passionate
people um
and like michael mentioned before as as
long as
one of our leadership principles is
deliver results and
um as long workplace flexibility is a
huge plus for me as long as i'm i do
what i'm supposed to do it doesn't
matter whether i come to work at eight
or ten
absolutely i think it's that combination
of um learn and be curious and delivery
right you you you have the opportunity
and the invitation to just keep learning
and it's
it's very exciting ping
what what excites you i think you're the
longest tenured member of our panel
so what what keeps you excited and
staying at amazon for
15 years now yeah it's crazy crazy to
think about that time um of course
sometimes i do wake up and kind of like
wait wait a minute what am i doing here
it's been so long
somewhere else you know uh but you know
you get over it
in a sense that um i think
intellectually speaking
i'm sure everyone here has that point of
view is
we all want to go to a place there are
interesting problems to solve
they're telling people to work with and
there's a community that you can bounce
ideas off that can support each other
so those are obviously kind of things
you take off but i would say
probably speaking uh for amazon the top
two things on my list
is one is i'm calling empowerment uh
just like folks here before me said
the sense that you feel like you can
drive what we
what you believe is the right thing to
do and it doesn't matter
nobody's gonna say and say hey so and so
you can't do this because you're
you're only level x you're not the right
level or you can't do this because
you're in this organization
but not the other organization it just
it doesn't happen that way
you can you can feel empowered to drive
the things that you want to drive
i think that's that's really important
um and two is i do think
innovation it's important it's still
very important for i think this very
scientific minded folks because science
is really about experiments right and i
think if you look at how
jeff b talks about it um in terms of
culture of experimentation the
willingness to
try things and fail is very much in the
culture of the amazon and i think that's
also very important
to the scientists
absolutely i think that that scientific
mindset
is present at all levels within amazon
which i think is really exciting
when you see our um our directors and
our vice presidents and our senior vice
presidents being just as excited about
the innovation and the experimentation
as our as our you know entry level folks
who just got their phds i think it's
um it really permeates all levels which
is very exciting
muge what about you well peeing islam
and irene
covered a lot of the great things that
make us stay here for really long years
more than a decade right for me until
now
um i think in addition to that for me
i'm really i'm most excited about
solving heart problems
um it's one of my favorite things about
working here
and i also love that no matter what your
background is
as long as you're curious and passionate
and obsessed with innovation
you can't do anything you can't be
anything here there's just no boredom
and
i think i'm a good example of that i
joined as a research scientist
to create mathematical models and you
know tested out different things tried
different things and i realized that my
passion
is on the business side and i'm now
running
really large businesses and creating big
impact for
our customers so uh
you know among many many things i think
those two are the key ones for me
yeah i think that sort of takes us full
circle because i think aslan was talking
about
impact as well and that's always like a
a big thing i think
for a lot of scientists that end up at
amazon right is that is that feeling of
like yes
i know the theory but i'm getting to put
it into practice
and and see the impact on our customers
at the end of the day
and that's a really exciting feeling
um so speaking sort of to the audience
of folks that may be
listening in i'm curious if
um any of you can speak to your
experience working with
interns at amazon we have um many
we have a fairly strong culture of
internship at amazon
um so i'm curious if you can either talk
about working with interns at amazon
or if you could go back to when you were
a student maybe what would you tell
yourself
um and muge do you have any any thoughts
on this
yeah i love working with interns we have
had
medical terms and oh that's my dog sorry
many thousand
last mile and um many of them have gone
on to be successful in full-time roles
at amazon and there are many intern
projects that go on to become the
foundation of something that becomes a
core part of how we operate
um you know learn ambiguous like we've
talked about
embrace your project be an owner and be
you um when interning at a company like
amazon there's so much to learn it can't
feel overwhelming
however i think remembering that no one
expects you to know everything on day
one
uh it is important just kind of going to
your question as to what advice do you
have
um my dog really wants to go out of my
office right now uh but it's you know
research a lot
there are tons of good resources here
uh number two would be keep asking
questions
your teammates would have had to learn
many of the same things you are learning
and we love hearing those fresh
perspectives from the interns
uh number three on your project i think
islam was talking about this a lot right
like
while you may specialize in a particular
area
here you're empowered to think
holistically
and provide feedback and ideas um
whether you're an intern or a full-time
employee or a director or a vp here
we love seeing this type of ownership in
our interns so embrace your project
make it yours um have an impact on the
customer experience
absolutely um aslam do you have
any experience working with interns
you'd like to talk about
well i i really like working with
interns because they bring fresh
fresh perspectives to the table they
make you realize uh
something you might have forgotten or
teach you and new methods so i really
like working with the new interns that
come to amazon
um my advice and general advice to
interns is to when they come here uh
or to any company i would advise them to
meet as many people as they can
um to form those relationships and those
relationships would
you know those meetings would help them
discover what's out on the field and
they would help them discover what they
are passionate about
and if possible i would advise them to
do as many internships as their studies
allow them to each company is different
an internship is a time
time time to explore
awesome okay um
so we also have a couple of uh
pre-submitted questions that we're going
to be talking through
um so the first one says what is
new and exciting in optimization at
amazon
and how can you overcome barriers to be
successful
and um we're gonna ask muge to answer
this
to start okay um so
like i mentioned i am in our last mile
delivery space
which is relatively new for amazon um
you know amazon flex which is one of my
programs
um was launched five years ago and you
know one of the
one of the things that we're trying to
do is to achieve
really fast we call it ultra fast ultra
fast grocery deliveries
um or even for your regular amazon.com
um deliveries the brownbox deliveries of
getting the speed to be faster and
faster so that we can get the product to
customer
at really fast speeds and so that of
course
um opens up different opportunities in
optimization
i think one of them is unique and
unparalleled of constraints and solving
for capacity
we need to figure out we need to secure
delivery partner or driver
capacity to be able to go and pick up
the packages and it's ultra fast and you
have very tight window
speed so if you um shop that prime now
you could order and you could actually
get that product in 45 minutes
which is really tight and you know we
have another constraint just lowest cost
so it's a really hard problem but it's
fun
i think that is one um adding
to what i just said the factor that we
do work with independent contractors
so it's that fourth dimension increases
the complexity of the optimization
problem
even more because now you have
kind of this labor force where
you know it's take it or leave it type
of uh option they don't have to
uh work for us they don't have to take
that you know particular delivery
opportunity
um i think that's another one that's
that's we've been you know working on
quite a bit
uh i think the other part and this
applies for anywhere at amazon is
we're so dynamic right like one day
we're solving we're trying to solve this
problem and then the next day
that problem evolves to be something
different so like i mentioned
before just no boredom to never static
you're always going to be
adding to the models that you have or
you know you're going to be moving to
solving a completely different
set of problems
absolutely true um
[Music]
okay awesome what about you um what is
it
that you're finding new and exciting at
amazon and how are you overcoming
barriers to be successful
um what i what i see around
uh around me lately is like new advances
and optimization is just availability of
data it's so much easier to get data now
so much easier to store data and um
it's this opens up many many
opportunities to analyze and use it
um in in many ways that wasn't possible
before
um including machine learning and um
different types of optimization models
and that that's my two cents
absolutely ping how about you
yeah i think uh i think you have two
questions maybe let me ask
the first one it's really about what's
exciting in optimization
um you know i i think um my career is a
little
i don't know if it's different but it's
not a little bit non-linear
perhaps like mu gays um you know but it
we i started out as a really uh what we
call oh oisa or scientists within
amazon and then in the past 10 years
i've been really working on forecasting
so spending a lot of time with
statisticians and machine learning
scientists
um and so uh some of the exciting stuff
that i see is i'm calling it kind of the
integration of our ml and what i really
see that
is you know you have
typical these uh or models is you have
trying to approximate use mathematics
approximately uh
the real world and you're trying to
solve that problem exactly
so solve an exact problem of an
approximate problem
um and then you have ml which is very
much data driven
you know you're going to try to solve an
approximately uh but you're trying to
solve an exact problem because you have
all these historical data
anyway uh the contract is interesting uh
but here
here's an example kind of how i how we
think about the integration too
so in our business like we you know we
do this
skill forecasting we produce a
probabilistic forecast
for you know 500 million items for the
next one year
at the weekly grain and then that data
is passed through
uh to really essentially an optimization
system to make
supply chain decisions about purchasing
about placement
about returning return to vendor
liquidation
and what we found and being asking
ourselves is that well that's great each
of these problems are really hard
but can we even do better by solving a
one problem
so instead of doing a two-step of here's
a prediction and then here's an
optimization
can we do the whole thing so we are
actually looking at deep
influence learning i'm trying to
essentially use ml
to see if we can solve this curse of
dimensionality
in these large dynamic programs so that
would just be one example
but i think it's super exciting that
there's just tons of opportunity
exciting problems here
absolutely and i think that that's sort
of one of the overarching themes that
we've been talking about
as we've been talking about what keeps
us here what's exciting what's new
has absolutely been sort of the
innovation piece at amazon um
and so like i just want to thank
everybody i want to thank our panelists
and i also want to thank all of you who
have given us you know
some of your time today to listen in to
our discussion
um for more information or if you'd like
to learn
about any opportunities at amazon you
can reach out to us
at informs2020 at amazon.com
and you can also visit amazon.science
to stay up to date on recent news and
announcements
that's amazon.s c i
e n c e amazon.science um
and there's a great landing page there
that talks about um
all of our different science programs so
thanks again for joining us
and have a great morning afternoon
evening whatever time it is
that you're viewing this video thanks
again
thank you tessa for moderating thanks
everyone
thank you thank you